[Music]
right so for me this morning Time
magazine is revealing its annual list of
the 100 most influential people in the
world the 2018 time 100 list includes
world leaders news makers athletes and
entertainers of course actresses Nicole
Kidman Jennifer Lopez and Tiffany
Haddish go you all are featured on three
of the six special covers Microsoft CEO
Satya Nadella tennis star Roger Federer
and me - movement founder tirana Burke
are on the other three-time
editor-in-chief Edward Felsen Thal joins
us in studio 57 at the table for the
first time why because this is your
first time as editor-in-chief Congrats
and go you thanks Edward bangs on table
we're delighted over here so what makes
this different and what excites you most
you know this is the time there's always
a reflection of the moment and I think
we live in a surprising moment and the
list is surprising as a result in really
interesting ways it's the youngest list
we've ever had what does that mean it
means we well we have 45 and a hundred
people are under age 40 great we also
have Milly Bobby Brown the youngest
person ever on the list at 14 but I
think it's a reflection of the changing
ways that influence is wielded in our in
our culture doesn't know a zip code or
an a/b more women and more people of
colors there are I could say there are
and it's it's you know it the list is a
reflection of what's happening in the
culture what's happening in politics and
business and and you see the changes
we've all been watching with awe
reflected and who's on it and when you
talk about what's happening in the
culture let's be more specific I mean
the the information flows are
democratized it's no longer old white
men who are the gatekeepers for things
in a way the Time magazine of 1923 was a
gatekeeper now a lots of these people
are coming into the culture from all
kinds of different angles it's much less
you see less the influence and impact of
institutions and more the impact of
influence of individuals do you have the
Parkland High School students and Barack
Obama wrote their introduction
I love the pairings that you do the
parents you know we like to think of it
as the time 200 because we really do
carefully choose the hundred people we
asked to write and bring fresh light to
some of these
faces in the case of the parkland kids
new faces and there are many people on
the list who were not household names a
year ago and are now and Barack Obama
rights you know he said before the
failure of common-sense gun control was
one of his greatest frustrations really
a single greatest frustration and he
writes with all about what the kids have
been able to accomplish
did he take edits the president minor
edit yes you also have many figures key
figures from the hashtag me to movement
why was it important to include some of
them including the reporters who broke
many of these stories Jodie can turn
Megan to it yes
you know despite it all despite the
attacks on the press despite a lot of
turmoil in the you know the business of
media this has been an amazing year for
journalists and for journalism and and
we felt it was important to recognize
the impact of people who bring these
stories to light that wouldn't otherwise
be told and how did you decide on the
politicians it made the less we saw jeff
sessions made the list well it's it's
it's been a crazy year of course in
politics and trying to figure out who
from the administration should be on the
list is a challenge because you never
know exactly who's in the administration
and and who he's talking to he shakes up
his staff he shakes up the routine of
where he takes advice from some of the
people we had from the illustration on
the list last year are gone so so it's
it's a different list in that sense to
and this is not a Betty Crocker seal of
approval this is not a value judgment
you can have influence whether it's good
or bad influence haven't any fur
absolutely all right looking forward to
the big dinner are you I am I am it'll
be great it's always a very nice
congratulations thank you thanks for
having me